My name is Anikait.
I'm a TA here for CS 224R.
And I hope you guys
are in the right place
for the Q-Learning lecture.
So just as a general overview,
what we're going to cover,
we're going to start off
by just doing a very, very
brief overview of MDPs.
Hopefully at this
point, you guys
will be somewhat familiar
with the notation.
And then we're
going to switch over
to talking a little bit about
a more controlled or tabular
problem where we're going to be
looking at fitted Q iteration
as an algorithm, and
how we can build up
from the tabular setting to
learn an effective function.
And then we're going to move
on to parametric Q-learning,
looking at the bias
and variance trade-off,
learning from TD regression
versus Monte Carlo rollouts.
And then finally
talk a little bit
about some of the practical
details that go into learning
effective Q functions.
So this includes things
like the replay buffer
that we just briefly chatted
about, overestimation,
and how to deal with the
gradient effects of TD learning.
So an MDP or a Markov
Decision Process.
So as you guys have
been probably looking
at in the last
couple of lectures,
we've defined a
framework for us to look
at [? RLs ?] where
we have an agent
on the right-hand side that is
interacting with an environment.
And we define this
framework of an MDP
that's defined by a set
of states and actions,
and also a transition
dynamics function
which allows you to go
from a certain state,
take a particular action,
and go to the next state.
You're also rewarded for a
particular state and action
that you take, as well
as have different metrics
like the starting
state, which tells you
where in the
trajectory you're from,
and things like the discount
factor and horizon, which
allow you to encourage
longer or shorter horizon
trajectories where your horizon
is the length of the trajectory.
In this lecture,
we'll be talking
a little bit about the
GridWorld assignment--
sorry, this GridWorld
problem on the top right
where we have this
little robot that's
trying to navigate to
this gem on the top right.
And similar to classes
we've seen before,
our goal is to maximize the
expected return conditioned
on a policy that
we're trying to learn,
where a policy is simply
defined as a set of actions
for each state in this
tabular environment
that should be taken to
reach a particular goal.
So in the past
couple of lectures,
we've been looking at a
certain set of objects which
we denote as value functions.
So we'll start off
by defining V pi of s
or a value function that
estimates the expected
future reward when
you start at a state s
and follow your policy pi.
We also have this other useful
object called the Q function
where the distinction between a
value function and a Q function
is that now you additionally
condition on an action
and look at what the expected
future reward looks like when
you follow your policy.
So both of these quantities are
an estimate of how good either
a current state is or a
state and a particular action
is to give you guidance for
your policy in terms of what
actions I should
potentially take.
So if we look at, for
example, a set of trajectories
as seen here, your
value function,
which is only
conditioned on the state,
estimates from a given state
how well, if I follow my policy,
will I do going forward.
And a Q function gives you a
little bit more information
where you can probe a particular
action for an immediate action
that you can take.
And consider, if I take this
action versus another one, what
my value can be.
And a useful relation
to know in this case is
that your value function that
you've learned on the left
is like an expectation,
the Q function
that you'll learn on the right.
Another useful quantity that
you might have already seen
is this notion of
an advantage, which
estimates how useful it is to
take a particular action A,
then follow the policy
at the current time step.
So to understand
this we denote this.
We define the advantage as the
difference between the key value
and the value as
seen on the bottom.
So to explore how you
can learn a Q function,
we're going to go back to this
tabular GridWorld environment
that we've been
looking at and see
how we can learn a Q function
through dynamic programming.
So in class, you might have
seen this Bellman equation
as seen on this slide here,
which is defined as the expected
reward to go where we look
at the transition dynamics
from a current
state st multiplied
by the reward at the
current time step
when we take a
particular action,
as well as added to the max of
the Q-value at the next state.
We can then convert
this Bellman equation
which gives you the
optimal Q function
into an iterative
learning process where
we are going to define our
Q function at each time step
starting from the Q time step
at the previous time step
and doing this same
maximization procedure.
So you'll start off with
maybe an empty GridWorld where
your value function-- or Q
function here is starting off
at 0 at all steps.
And then you iteratively,
starting from your terminal
states, propagate reward
from your terminal
states back to all states
within your GridWorld.
So we'll see pictorially
how that will happen.
But this is an
iterative process that
allows you to propagate
value from any terminal state
to all states within
your GridWorld.
This is the foundation
of TD learning or Q
learning in general, and
is how we'll visualize this
in the next couple of slides.
So in this GridWorld environment
that we're going to look at,
we're going to have,
again, this robot that's
in this toy environment where it
can have five different actions
that it can take at every step.
It can either stay
in its current spot,
move left, move right,
move up, or move down.
And we're going to be rewarding
it if it lands in the top right
square and penalizing
it with a negative value
if it lands in this square
in the middle up here.
Additionally, we have this
notion of a discount factor
to allow us to
encourage the robot
to reach the goal state
as quickly as it can
and not do spurious exploration.
So we'll start off with the
Q-value function defined
as the right here
where for every state
it's essentially going to be
0, except for the terminal
states on the right
top up right hand
side, where for the
top right corner
it is plus 1 because it gets a
plus 1 reward when you terminate
there, and negative 1
for this lava square.
And we can then run
this propagation
for the Q-value over
multiple iterations.
And what we'll see is
that in time step 2,
the states very close
to the top right
seem to now get Q values
due to the propagation.
And eventually, over
multiple iterations,
we're able to fill up
the grid, leading us
to stable convergence
over Q function.
So what is the
particular difference
between the Bellman
equation and this equation?
Yeah.
That's a really good point.
So let me go back to
where I defined that.
Sorry.
So the Bellman equation here,
as you can see on the top,
has no subscript
denoting what iteration
you're updating the policy.
And all it's saying is that
for the optimal policy,
this relation will hold.
And then a natural
derivation from there
is that you can do this
iteratively where you start
from your terminal states which
already have a given reward,
and you know what that would
be, and propagate information
from that point to
then learn the true Q
function at every single state
and action in your state space.
So this is now going to have
a subscript k plus 1 or k
that represents what
iteration you're going
to be looking at for each step.
I guess the question
or clarification was,
which one of these is like Monte
Carlo or dynamic programming?
So right now we're going to be
looking at a dynamic programming
algorithm.
And a quick way to sanity
check that, or get a heuristic
sense of that, is that
if you see the Q function
on both sides of
your update, that
will generally be a dynamic
programming style of algorithm.
Whereas for a Monte
Carlo, you will
see strictly only
rewards, at least
for the Q-learning updates
and value function updates.
But right now we're looking at
a dynamic programming algorithm,
and that is why we start
from these terminal states
as we see here on the right.
And we then propagate value
to all states within our grid.
I'll start off by saying that--
is the state space here clear?
And the actions are going up,
down, left, right, and stay.
So these are just denoting
each of the five directions.
So the Q-value for being
at this state and going up
is the top value.
And going left is the
value on the left there.
The initial state of the
Q function just something
you made up?
The initial state
of the Q function?
Yeah.
No, it's not something
that I've made up.
So generally-- oh, sorry, I
haven't defined this here.
But Q0 is defined as all zeros
for all states in your tabular
setting.
So you generally typically
initialize your Q function
as zeros.
And then Q1 is just a single
update using the equation above.
And the reason that for these
states the reward is plus 1
and minus 1 is because
these are terminal states,
and then from any action
that you take at these states
will result in the reward.
So this is iteration one.
And from there, we just
do the dynamic programming
update as seen on the top.
And we see that the
value essentially
propagates from the top
state to any other state
in our GridWorld.
So in the class we've
been discussing,
notation is something that
you probably are maybe
getting overwhelmed with.
So I want to maybe clarify
a few different quantities
that you might
have seen and talk
about how it relates to the
current GridWorld's that we've
been exploring.
So the top left here,
which is V of s,
is going to be the
value function that is
unconditional on the actions.
And you can see that for every
state we assign it a value.
And we see that from the
top right corner, which
is the place where
you get a reward,
you essentially get
a reward of plus 1,
and the discounting of 0.9 then
applies for every state that
is far away from it.
So you can see that if
you're one step away,
you have a value of 0.9.
If you're two steps, it would be
like 0.81, so on and so forth,
until you complete the full
grid, except for the lava
state where you get a minus
1 reward for terminating.
Additionally,
there's the Q star,
which is the center thing
that we were just looking at.
And you can either get
this through convergence
of the algorithm that
we were just describing,
or you can also calculate
it analytically.
Finally, there is the policy.
And the policy is just going
to be a deterministic function
that's primarily
because, for any MDP
without any partial
observability,
the policy is going to be a
deterministic function that
is defined as strictly the
argmax of the Q function.
And as you can see
here, it typically
has a path towards the goal.
And it's generally
the shortest path
for any state in your GridWorld.
So these are all the optimal
value, Q-value, and policies.
For me looking at this
I think the policy
is pretty much all I need.
So what are the
different advantages?
Yeah.
That's a good question.
So you're saying that, OK, maybe
these things seem really extra.
I don't need to
actually learn them.
If I learn the policy,
I'm going to be all good.
That's a great question
and probably worth thinking
a little bit about.
So what you can think about is
that, in this tabular domain,
the way that we've
extracted the policy
is just by doing it
argmax of our Q function.
So we needed the
Q function to help
us determine what are the values
throughout the entire state
space, and we were able to
extract a policy from it.
There are also
approaches that only
utilize a policy, such as policy
gradient objectives, which
you might have explored in
the first couple of classes.
But they do experience some
amount of variance issues
in your environment.
We'll talk a little
bit about this
when we go to discuss the
differences between Monte Carlo
and TD.
But essentially, once
your environment ends up
having a lot of
variance, either in terms
of the reward or the
transition dynamics,
that results in policy
gradient methods
or Monte Carlo based methods
to solve for a little bit
because there's very high
variance in your environment.
So a Q value function
can allow you
to trade-off that
variance for bias
and is maybe another way to deal
with those specific environment
configurations.
So there are trade-offs
to learning each of them.
And certain environment
configurations
allow you to learn a Q
function better than others.
So those were the optimal
value, Q value, and policies.
Additionally, as I
discussed before,
there's also a notion of
an advantage which gives us
an estimate of how good
a particular action is
relative the action that your
policy would essentially take.
So for the optimal
policy, the advantage
should always be negative.
And the reason for that
is that your policy
is the optimal policy,
so there's no action
that's better than it.
And you can see this
in the GridWorld
on the right, where
there are actions
that are in red that go
towards the lava state,
for example, that are
negative in nature.
And all of the actions
that are from the policy
are all going to
have zero advantage
because they're equivalent.
So yeah.
So the advantage is zero for
actions from our current policy.
But for actions that are
not from the optimal policy
they're going to be negative.
So that is why for every action
that the optimal policy takes
in the GridWorld
on the top right,
the advantage is
going to be zero.
But for all other
actions, the advantage
will be negative because
they can be worse
performing than
the optimal policy,
because there could be, for
example, two actions that
lead to similar values, which
I think was an example I think
in the state on 0, 0.
So you can either go up or
to the right from the state,
and the advantage
for both of them
will be 0 because they
match to the optimal policy.
But the optimal policy
is deterministic,
so you'll end up picking
one of them as your policy.
So far we've been looking
at the optimal policy.
But what would it look like
for your current policy
or suboptimal one?
So here I'm going to
show, again, Q star of s,
a and pi of a given s, and Q
pi of s, a and pi of a given s.
So as you can see, this is
not a deterministic policy
on the bottom, and in
many cases actually
does not lead you to
the right set of actions
to take, sometimes even
leading to the lawless state,
for example.
And we can see that here
the Q function that's
associated with it is also
different from the optimal Q
function.
So you can learn a
critic or Q function that
is conditioned on a
policy that tells you
how close am I to
the optimal policy,
and how can I
improve using that.
So if I wanted to learn an
actor critic style algorithm,
for example, I could
use this critic
that's conditioned on
a particular policy
to tell me what are actions that
might be better than the ones
that I'm taking, and
use that to update the
to do one step of improvement.
Q store, on other hand,
has been converged,
so the optimal
policy can no longer
be updated because of that.
This is just to give
you a sense of what
the different notation means.
So Q pi just relates
to the current policy,
whereas Q star is
the optimal one.
If you guys would
like to play around
with some of these
tabular environments,
feel free to do so through the
Colab in the PDF that I shared.
We've been talking a little
bit about these tabular
environments, and it's great
to play around with these girls
and see how values and stuff
propagate, but with something
like this actually scale.
And unfortunately,
it doesn't seem
to be the case because a tabular
value function, as your state
or action space grows, will have
thousands or millions of rows,
and it will be really
hard to learn that.
Additionally, if you instead
learn a parametric value
function through a neural
network or something,
you can allow for generalization
to occur in a better way.
So for example, if you have
two states that are close
to each other, either
in a semantic sense
or a literal sense,
you would hope
that their Q-values are also
very similar to each other.
And this is like a
property of smoothness
that you get from the
underlying representation
that you've learned.
And what we'll look at next is
how to use regression techniques
to learn a value function
with a neural network
in both continuous and
discrete environments.
So we'll go back to
look at these figures
on the right-hand side
where the first figure here
is the value function that
is not conditional on state,
and this takes in
as input the state
and outputs a scalar
which is V pi of s.
Additionally, there's now
two types of Q functions
that you'll look at.
One is a continuous
Q function which
takes in both a state and an
action, and outputs a scalar,
as well as a discrete
value function
which outputs for a
given state a vector
for all possible actions
that you essentially have.
To be fair, you could also
use the left representation
to learn the discrete key
value, but generally, it's
advisable to do this
as long as you're
discrete space is tractable
because you have the ability
to enumerate all
actions in your space.
Yeah.
So there's a discrete Q function
and a continuous Q function,
but for the value function it's
irrelevant to the action space.
So there's only one general
parameterization people
use there.
For the discrete Q function,
what you can actually do
is that you can
predict the action--
sorry, predict the Q value
for all actions in your space,
and then you can choose
the particular one
that you'd want to use.
For example, let's say that
there are four actions.
In the GridWorld that we
had four to five actions,
you can predict the Q value for
up, down, left, right, and stay.
Whereas for a
continuous space, it
would be really hard to
enumerate all possible actions,
so you generally take
that as input instead.
So in a continuous
space, you typically
condition on a action
and output a scalar.
And when you do an
expectation calculation here,
you typically sample
actions from your policy
in order to do so.
We have this robotic
policy, and you
can see that we are
predicting values for it
at every single state.
Whereas for discrete
case, so you
can output a value
for each bin and then
enumerate over all of them
when you take an expectation.
So an advantage of
doing the bottom case
is that if you're
doing an expectation,
you can enumerate all
actions, and you'll
get an exact estimate
of your expectation,
whereas on top it's just
a sample-based estimate.
So let's dive a little bit into
how to actually do Q-learning
as a regression problem.
And I'll use the whiteboard
on the right here.
So we're going to be working
with basically V pi of s.
And you can do a similar
derivation for Q of s as well.
This is adapted from the
Sutton and Barto textbook.
So our value, as
we've discussed,
is going to be conditioned
on a particular state,
and it can be modeled or it
represents the expected return
to go from that
particular state.
So we're going to
then write it now
as an expectation under our
policy pi of the return, Rt,
conditioned on our state s.
So the return can be now
expanded a little bit
to be equivalent to the
sum of discounted rewards.
So we're going to
quickly do that.
And this here is going to be--
sorry, I need to take
into account k here.
Gamma to the k st plus k and
at plus k given st equals s.
So what this
essentially is saying
is that from our
current point in time,
we're going to look at all
of the rewards going forward.
Discount them by our
discount factor, which
is exponentiated according to
how many time steps you are away
from your current
state, and look
at what the summation of
that would essentially be.
This, as you asked
about, is the Monte Carlo
estimate of our value function,
and it's denoted as a sum.
So we can do now some algebra to
convert this into a one step TD
estimate.
And the way that we're
going to do that is we're
going to take this reward
out of the summation
here and use it to go back to
the value function definition
that we'd had above.
So the first thing that I'll
do is that I'll remove r of st
at when k equals 0, and then
also apply the discounting here.
We're going to keep
the summation again
from k equals 0 to
infinity, and now we're
going to have this
summation again.
So this part on the right-hand
side is just going to be
an expansion--
sorry, this line here is just
an expansion of the line above.
We've just done some algebra.
So we can get it into a form
similar to the MC definition
that we've written above.
And what you'll notice
here is that this looks
a lot like a value function.
But now instead of
at the current state,
it is going to be
at the next state.
So we can now write this
as the following, e of st
plus 1 given st equals s.
And by doing so, we have now
arrived at our TD function.
So you might be asking, what
is the difference between doing
a Monte Carlo value estimate
versus doing a TD estimate?
And the main distinction
here is that we're
going to be representing
the Monte Carlo
estimate as the
discounted sum of returns
over our entire trajectory.
So this is going
to have no bias.
But instead here, when we
look at the TD estimate,
we're going to actually
substitute our value function
back in.
And this is going to
introduce some amount of bias
because our value function
here can be inaccurate.
But it will reduce our
variance because we're
going to reduce the
horizon of our trajectory.
So we're going from a horizon
of each, which can be very, very
large for a lot of problems
to just a horizon of one,
and this will reduce our
variance significantly
over the horizon.
So that is the TD
learning estimate
that we've described here.
So notice here that k equals 0.
So if I break up
this summation into--
let me just add this
as a step below.
So if I look at the
case where k equals 0,
it's going to be r of st plus
at plus the summation from k
equals 1 to infinity of gamma
to the k, r of st plus k.
Whoops.
at plus k, all
given st equals s.
So that is how we
remove that term.
And you can just do
some minor algebra
to convert it from the
step to the one on top.
So I'm going to
quickly erase this
because I also want to
talk about what an n step
return looks like.
So right now like what we did is
that we only expanded this once.
But we can also do
this expansion n times.
And what this will
allow us to do
is to trade-off between
the bias and the variance.
So the bias comes again from the
value function parametrization.
And the variance comes from
the horizon of your trajectory,
essentially.
Because as your reward
function might be noisy
or your transition
dynamics might be noisy,
you introduce a
little bit of variance
amongst all of the
trajectories that you roll out.
So let's look at
what that would be.
I'm just going to
quickly grab my iPad so I
don't make a notation mistake.
T
So basically what
we've done here
is that we've done
k steps of rolling
out using the same expansion
that we did for one step.
And now our value
function is discounted
by k steps instead of one step.
And we are now turning off
between the Monte Carlo rollout,
which is going to be the full
discounted sum of rewards,
as well as this value
function estimate that we do,
allowing us to effectively
trade-off between TD and Monte
Carlo.
So let's take a look at how this
would look in a visualization.
So I'll put both of
these up on the slide
so we can compare one by one.
But if you look at
the left-hand side,
what we're essentially doing is
that from a particular state,
we're going to let our policy
rollout until it reaches
a terminal state, and we're
going to collect multiple
of these rollouts
to do essentially
an update by collecting
these rollouts,
averaging the reward
amongst them to the reward
to go amongst them to calculate
this value function estimate,
and that can have
a lot of variance
because at every action, you
introduce this amount of noise
from your transition dynamics
function or the reward.
In contrast, with
this TD backup,
we're only going to do
one step of unrolling,
but we're going to then
use the value function
estimate at the next
state to then reduce
the variance of our estimate.
But again, because our value
function can be inaccurate,
that leads to potential
issues with bias.
And both of these have
some amount of trade-off.
Yeah.
So for tabular settings
both of these approaches
should converge to the
same resulting equation.
But when you go beyond
that they don't seem
to converge to the same thing.
And again, we're looking
at the n-step returns
here as well where we're going
to allow the TD target to look
n-steps in the future before
being applied so we could then
trade-off between the
bias and variance here.
And yeah, you can
look at this table
here to look at what the
trade-off of each of these
would be, where the
bootstrap depth of TD
is going to be one step.
For n-steps is going to be n.
And for Monte Carlo it's
going to be the full episode.
The bias for
something like TD is
going to be high,
whereas for n-steps it's
going to be somewhere
in the middle,
depending on how
large your k is.
And for Monte Carlo, you're not
going to have any bias at all.
And then the variance
would be the reverse
of this where TD has lower
variance with n-steps return
being somewhere again in
the middle and Monte Carlo
having high variance.
Again, this also depends
heavily on the environment
that you're in.
So for example, in language,
Monte Carlo rollouts
are actually the way that
a lot of people do things,
because in many cases,
your environment dynamics
are almost perfect, and your
reward signal, especially
in domains like math
or code reasoning,
are going to be perfect as well.
So you don't have to
worry about things
like variance of your dynamics.
But if you go to things
like maybe agentic domains
or robotic domains, a
lot of these factors
come back into play.
One other thing that dynamic
programming gives you
is this notion of stitching.
And if we look at
this maze environment
on the left-hand side,
you can see an example
of why this might be powerful.
So let's say that we've
collected through our policy
two different trajectories,
one that goes from A to B,
and another that
goes from C to D.
Through this one step of dynamic
programming, what you'll see
is that you can actually
find the optimal path from A
to D because of the
fact that at every step
you're looking like
one step before it,
and you can stitch these
trajectories together
to form what the optimal
path would be to the goal.
So this allows you to get
better coverage of your space,
and allows these
algorithms to potentially
be somewhat more efficient.
Any questions about this?
If not, then let's
talk a little bit more
about some of the practical
design details that are needed
to get Q-learning to stabilize.
The first thing that
we'll quickly talk about
is this notion of a
semi-gradient or target network.
And we're now going to look
back at our Q value estimate
that we've been looking at
so far, where we define it
as the reward at the
current time step,
plus the discounted Q value
at the next time step.
We'll look at the
max over all actions.
So what you'll see here is
that the Q function on the left
is going to be the same as
the Q function on the right,
but this will make
optimization very difficult,
especially if you like
propagate gradients through it.
So one trick that people
do use is this notion
of a semi-gradient, which
allows you to freeze your target
network or not pass any
gradients to it to make
optimization a little
bit more stable,
and that's defined as the second
equation that I defined here.
Additionally, to further make
things a little bit more stable,
people add in this notion
of a target network, which
delays the updates of
the right-hand side
to allow your Q function to
regress to a more stable target.
And there are two
types of updates
that people use in this space.
One is this notion of a
hard target update where,
at a fixed frequency, you allow
the model to essentially update
to the most recent
model that you've used.
Additionally, you can
also use this notion
of a soft target update or of
an EMA or Polyak style averaging
technique, which allows
you to smoothly interpolate
between the Q functions that
you've seen so far with a decay
parameter.
In practice, people, I think,
try to use the on the right.
Both of them empirically have
been seen to work somewhat well.
And the reason that
you want to do this
is that you want to make
sure that when you're
doing some amount of regression,
your value function is a really
stable target to approach.
And some of these
things like removing
the gradient on the
right-hand side,
as well as introducing
a target network,
makes the learning
problem a lot easier.
There are things that
you'd have to consider
in terms of how frequently
you update your target network
and things like that.
But for most cases,
people have stabilized
this as a hyperparameter to
around 0.99, for example,
for the Polyak averaging.
Typically when you're
learning a Q function,
you would learn this
through a regression
style of technique, which
would look something like this.
So I'm just going to, again,
do the value function update
to match what we have there.
So on this side here,
this is going to basically
be our loss quantity.
This is essentially just--
for a single sample estimate
what our loss would be.
And basically we have a learned
network on both sides of our MSE
which will be very unstable
to basically learn from.
What a stop gradient
essentially does
is that it prevents you
from passing gradients
to the right-hand side.
So your target is
going to be fixed
when you can't pass
any gradients to it,
but you can pass gradients
through your network
on the left-hand side.
So in this case, when you
do the semi-gradient trick,
it's going to keep the
same set of parameters
but not pass
gradients through it,
but the target network is in
a completely different set
of parameters that is
independent of the parameters
that you've learned,
and you then
update them through this
Polyak averaging, which
I was showing here.
So you have these sets
of weights, the w prime.
And w is maybe the weights
of your current network.
And every so often, for
a hard target update,
you would update them, or
for your Polyak averaging,
you would update
them at every step
but with this soft
ratio averaging.
This one here?
Yes, so this would
be exactly the term
that we were looking
at here as our target.
OK, let me be a little
bit more precise.
So let's say we have
a target value, which
looks as our reward at
our current time step
plus the discounted
value, our next time step.
So this is the one
step TD approach
that we're taking there.
And then our loss would
look something like this.
It's our value at
our current time step
minus y, is like
an MSE star loss.
So this is what the
right-hand side represents.
This is like the TD loss here.
So we're not done yet in terms
of how to fix the gradients
or making this a little bit
more stable, unfortunately.
There are a few other
types of techniques
people have used to make this
converge a little bit better.
The first is gradient
clipping, which
you might have seen
in things when you've
trained networks in the past.
Where if you have a
gradient that's too large,
which unfortunately comes a lot
of the time when you do updates
like TD, you want to
clip them a little bit
to allow you to do optimization
a little bit more stably.
And here you can see,
in this lost landscape,
for example, on the left, if
you don't do gradient clipping,
you go around the
optimal parameter space.
Whereas if you do some
gradient clipping,
you can smoothly approach it.
Additionally, you can use
objectives other than MSE
to make this a
little bit better.
And one standard
thing people have used
is this notion of
a Huber loss, which
is an interpolation between an
L1 and L2 loss, where it allows
you to not be affected by
outliers through the L1 loss,
which is this one in green.
But then when you get
close to the right answer
or the right value, you
allow for an L2 loss
to kick in and get you closer
and closer to the target value.
So this is like
the interpolation
that you're essentially
doing by this.
There are other things
that people have done,
but these are some
standard things
that people have found to help
with learning value functions.
Now let's get to replay buffers.
So one thing that you might have
seen in lecture, either today
or last week, was this notion of
replay buffer, which is a memory
structure that you can use to
store past experiences that
have been seen by an agent.
And the way that
we parametrize this
is in this buffer
like format right here
where we have these
tuples of state action
rewards and next states.
And we store them individually
as transitions instead
of trajectories as a whole.
And the reason that
we want to do it
that way is that it
allows us to break down
the temporal
correlations of our data
set, and also allow us
to prevent recency bias.
So there are two things
that come into play.
So the temporal correlations
come from the fact
that, at every time step, we
sample transitions rather than
trajectories.
And this can be across
trajectories as well.
So I can sample any set of
indices across my entire data
set, and they can be
from trajectories 1
through n, which are the
maximum of trajectories
I have in the data set.
Additionally, by having this
buffer of past trajectories
that I've visited, I
can avoid recency bias
by making sure that I don't
overfit to my current policy
because one thing that
Q-functions benefit from
is having a lot of
coverage in the space,
and this allows you to not
narrow down the distribution
by your current policy.
And all of these lead to
better sample efficiency
when you want to
learn Q-functions,
and it allows the agent
to reuse its experience
in an effective way.
So this is just going to denote
that your replay buffer can
sometimes have a
max size, depending
on how much capacity you have.
Typically, this
is not a concern.
But if do you might want to
either reweigh or throw out
parts of your buffer as needed.
I think people have
explored both RNN and even
transformer-based architectures.
There works like
decision transformer,
for example, that do
conditioning on long horizons
to predict both actions and
values and things like that,
and they all have different
amounts of trade-offs.
For learning critics
or Q functions,
it's definitely very
feasible to do so.
For policies, in language, for
example, we do this by default.
But in other places
like robotics
where you might have temporal
correlations in your data,
learning with history might be
actually a more nuanced topic
and can actually lead to more
design decisions needing to be
made to do this more carefully.
But yeah, it's definitely
an interesting area
to consider of how can I keep
in history all of the states
and actions that I've
seen so far, or maybe even
from previous trials,
and things like that.
I now want to quickly chat
about Q-learning overestimation.
So this is going to
follow a derivation using
function approximation from RL.
And again, we're going
to look at, again,
Q-learning like Bellman or
TD backup as seen on the top.
And one thing that
you might notice here
is that we have this max
operation on the right hand
side.
And what happens,
essentially, if we
have some noise
in our Q function
when we try to learn
it in this way?
And this is what we're
basically going to look at.
So essentially, when we are
parameterizing this Q function
as a neural network, there
can be noise in the estimation
that we incur.
And we're going to denote
our Q function currently
as approximate, which is
the learned parametrization.
And Q target here is
the optimal Q function
or the true
underlying Q function.
And we're now also going to
introduce this Y parameter here
that denotes some
amount of noise that
might be present due to
things like modeling errors.
And what we'll see
is that if there
is noise on the
right-hand side when we're
trying to predict the
target, this actually
transfers pretty badly
to the left-hand side.
So what we're actually looking
at here on the left-hand side
is, what would the Q values
look like after one step
of iteration, and how does that
differ from the true target
Value
So Q approx of s
prime a hat is going
to be basically what we see
on the right-hand side there,
and Q target is what
the true value would be.
And what we're
going to see here is
that if we define even a
noise that is of zero mean,
eventually the noise on
the left hand side, which
is going to be after
one step of update,
will have a positive mean
leading to a Q values
to be overestimated.
So this results in us having to
deal with this overestimation
issue when we're trying
to learn our critics.
I think one thing
that I mentioned
here is that we're going to do
a maximization over actions.
There could be issues, for
example, with sampling as well.
Actually I don't think
that's necessarily
the case because your true
target value over all actions
might be actually
higher, in that case,
than if you only look at a
subset of your total actions.
So in that case,
then, this property
would not necessarily
be an issue.
I think the main concern
actually just comes
from modeling errors,
because in some cases,
you might actually overestimate
your Q value on the right.
And once you do multiple
rounds of dynamic programming,
this error will propagate
through your entire state space
and will compound, essentially.
Let me clarify a little bit.
What I mean here by an
error or an overestimation
is actually in the
Q function and not
in the actions that were taken.
Let's assume that we can
enumerate all actions
in the discrete space
that we're working in.
And we look at the
value for each of them.
What the failure case
I'm describing here
is what the difference
is between the Q
function that we're learning
versus the true or optimal Q
function or Q star.
And what can happen is
that your Q function
can be incorrectly
modeled, maybe
due to some noise is higher than
what the true target actually
is.
And what I'm saying is
that even if that noise has
zero mean, when you do these
dynamic programming updates,
it propagates to
the left-hand side
and allows you to
essentially get
nonzero mean noise that's being
added due to this max operation.
And this essentially propagates
through your entire state space
and makes your Q values
blow up, resulting
in this overestimation.
Actually, I was going to go
through this a little bit later,
but we can talk about it now.
So imagine that this
is our state space--
sorry, there are a lot of
columns in this figure.
And we can look at each step
what the value estimate of looks
like.
What I am showing
in the second column
here is the difference in the
estimate and the max value
the Q function can
essentially have.
So you can look at
the left-hand side
and essentially telling you what
the max that the next time step
could essentially be.
And the third here shows
what the difference
is between the true value and
the value that we want to learn.
And if you look at
this red figure, which
is typical Q-learning
style algorithms,
we can see that there's a
huge error bar just because
of the fact that we're
overestimating what
the true value can be,
and we're propagating that
through all of the states.
I'll talk about how we
essentially fix this.
And one approach that
people have taken
is this notion of
critic ensembling
where we want to estimate the
epistemic uncertainty of our Q
function using an
ensemble of networks.
And we can then use all of
these ensemble of networks
and minimize over
the ensemble to get
an underestimate of what the
Q value should essentially be.
The reason that this
works is that you
can imagine that when you
initialize your network,
they're initialized in
different ways, and the errors
that they will get
across states is also
going to be very different.
So you can reduce
the uncertainty
or remove these modeling
errors by ensembling and then
doing something like a min
reduction over all of them.
And this has been shown
to be effective in works
like double Q-learning which
I'll show in the next slide,
as well as things like
offline RL, which we'll
talk about later, where
essentially you can increase
your ensemble size quite a lot,
and the distribution shift is
actually mitigated because
of ensembling pretty heavily,
and learning an underestimation
of what the Q value should
essentially be removing
you from getting
an overestimation due
to things like noise.
So the figure that I
described essentially
goes through exactly this.
And this is from the
double Q-learning paper.
And like what we see is that
in the figure on the right,
despite the red
curve here, which
is standard q-learning having
very large errors, just
having ensemble size of two
or doing double Q-learning
allows you to mitigate a lot
of these overestimation errors
for Q-learning and makes
things a lot stable.
So for online
Q-learning algorithms,
you can get away
with just doing two,
and for most intents and
purposes like that works
really well and
beyond that saturates.
But you can definitely try
to increase that for things
like offline reinforcement
learning where
the problem setting that
you're looking at there
is that you have a static data
set that you're working with.
And any errors that
happen because you
leave the support of your
current state or action
distribution allows
your model to propagate
these errors even more.
So there, I think being very
careful about the distribution
that you're in matters a lot.
And you can increase the
ensemble size for approaches
like [? Edak ?] or [? Sakan, ?]
for example, that do this.
There are ways that
have been looking
at this in the context of
language for reward modeling,
because in reward
modeling you're
going to face similar effects
with maybe overestimation,
potentially, and that
reduced the performance.
So there have been
papers that have come out
that just do things
like Laura or make sure
that you share a lot of
the layers of your network
and have linear adapters
or something beyond that,
and those are parameter
efficient ways
to learn something like this.